One of the interesting things about the multiverse
is that it raises questions about probabilities
that we still don't really quite know how
to answer.
The issue is that everything that is allowed
by the laws of physics, happens in an infinite
multiverse an infinite number of times.
So, for example, you might want to compare
the number of births of one-headed cows with
the number of births of two-headed cows.
And you'd naturally think there are a lot
more one-headed cows than two-headed cows.
But if there's an infinite number of both,
one really needs some way of regulating things
in order to be able to talk about what's the
ratio of two-headed cows to one-headed cows.
The current status of things is that we can
devise ways of regularizing these probabilities
of turning the infinities into finite ratios.
But there are different ways of doing it.
There's no unique solution.
And it even turns out that some of the simple
things that you might try turn out to give
results that are very crazy sounding.
So we think that we have narrowed down a range
of possible prescriptions for defining probabilities.
But we still don't know the answer to what
is it that actually determines what are the
correct probabilities in the context of the
multiverse.